would you ever resort to using AI in
court and can a computer that's
self-aware keep you from the electric
chair a robot is going to advise a
defendant in court for the first time
ever next month amazing but that's
nothing Steve Ducey has been at Fox for
25 years
wow I didn't even know that was coming
on in the courtroom and then tell to the
defendant what to say via an earpiece
this is technology I could definitely
use when he's space out on the five
listen to Jesse Waters
its creator says he could one day
replace lawyers because it's all about
having a Mastery of legal language and
that's what they charge hundreds of
dollars an hour to do the company that
created the app is called do not pay
which is also what I said when they
hired cat
it was originally developed by a
Stanford student in 2015 to fight
parking tickets and trust me that's way
easier than seducing all those meter
maids right those carts have a very
tight back seat
okay
that's amazing imagine having this thing
like your phone and every legal question
you just put it in there because it has
every case ever it can make better
decisions than any judge or any lawyer
yeah well that's why the government will
stop it or influence it because there
would be some government regulation
there and then at least in the case of a
criminal case your representation would
actually be influenced by the
prosecution
interesting I don't know what you said
there
because I was looking at my notes but I
think the way she said it was pretty
smart all right Murray here's the thing
the best I'll get yeah but it's good it
was a compliment here's the thing I
think they're doing it already with
medicine it's like they compile every
study ever into a database right and
then if they take a picture of your mole
they can submit it and
and all of a sudden you go nope the
moles non-cancerous if you have all the
information ever in the history of the
world in one spot that's better than
four years of med school it's better
than law school it's better than
anything well this is really good news
in general because everyone talks about
like automation they always say oh it's
going to take jobs from like truckers
and things like this if it could only
take all the jobs from the lawyers yes
ah they're so
yes there's so many things there's so
many things I love about this country
but the one of the things I love the
least is there are so many damn lawyers
yes exactly too many lawyers and if we
can make lawyers automated
you know life would just be that much
better if you think that the AI lawyers
better than Trump's lawyers so for sure
for sure I think they are lawyers are
better than Merritt Garland yes I mean
that's even money yes yeah exactly I'm
all for it count me in yeah I agree I
agree Tyrus I love this for the for the
very simple fact information
you could you know but there's also a
downside like every time you tell your
story and your AI goes guilty
[Laughter]
trust me plead out like
but no I want to do this I want to do
this you might want to go with a person
because you did that that's
so true because you're uh sleazy Lord
would say don't tell me yeah or even if
they do we can we'll try to work an
angle on it you know that's best case
you get a documentary yeah it's better
the other side but here's the the
downside is that the justice system is a
lot of time favored the wealthy this
would put into that right because the
you know when you have arguments and
there's no emotion
you know and then oh then what would the
what we can't say it was a racist
decision anymore you know because all
the AI stuff will be built by poor tiny
brown and yellow children in China and
Africa so its roots are not so there'll
be no white supremacy able to get in
there yeah so you know it's like fair I
think it's fair I like it this is the
answer to everything
all right where am I hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else